[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the President of the United
States is in a way not truly seen since
Woodrow Wilson a century ago an active
belligerent virulent white nationalist
dedicated to rolling back the rights of
and ruining the lives of Americans of
color and as this Dhaka non decision
decision pawned off on the evil Keebler
Elf of southern apologist shows he is
also a coward demanding that others in
this case Congress do the worst of his
dirty work for him who could have
believed that a creature whose campaign
began two years ago with a vile
psychotic assault on Mexicans and
Americans of Mexican descent actually
meant it well millions of us did
millions of us saw right through him and
prophesied this moment when the screws
would be tightened alike on the
technically guilty and the ultimately
innocent among those who did not see or
who pretended not to see the politicians
voters analysts reporters who is late as
the weekend passed we're still bleating
about Trump's latest last chance to be
presidential and most importantly and
disgustingly the mainstream Republicans
who rode trump's evil coattails to
victory and then figured the stain of
his hatred would somehow wash off the
rest of these shameless opportunists who
will be damned in history for what they
were enablers of the worst American
president of all time and the worst
elected leader in the history of all the
Western democracies who set out to
rapidly and thoroughly destroyed the
nation which had foolishly empowered him
and now it is up to those voters and
those Republicans to atone for their
sins that will damn them to hell
political or otherwise they must defend
800,000 Americans who came here or in
most cases were brought here as children
nearly half of them before their sixth
birthday about whom the Bible these
Republicans endlessly thumped without
seemingly ever opening tells us in
Ezekiel the son shall not bear the
iniquity of the father
these trumpian enablers must
act in defense of these Americans who
are far more worthy of citizenship here
than Trump or the other diseased minds
who have scapegoated them and most
especially they must act in memory of
the one who has come to most symbolize
them all
Alonzo Guillen he was a disc jockey from
Lufkin Texas here since he was a
teenager
most recently under the protection of
daca he was 31 he travelled more than a
hundred miles to Houston to volunteer in
a boat to look for victims of Hurricane
Harvey he had disappeared into the
night's water last Wednesday his family
kept vigil near Spring Texas and Sunday
afternoon Alonzo Gans body floated past
them he is dead and at last word the
Trump administration would not let his
mother into this country for the funeral
Alonzo Guillen died trying to save his
fellow Americans in Houston while this
filth Trump saw his chance to sell
copies of the cap he wore in Houston for
$40 new Republicans and you Trump
supporters must now pass a veto-proof
daca bill it became an Obama executive
order only after it passed the house but
was killed by the Republicans
filibustering in the Senate you
Republicans and Trump supporters
especially those of you who are
yourselves of color must atone not
merely because it is the right thing to
do after this daca debacle after the
Nazis and their torches in
charlottesville after the wall after the
RPO pardon after the increased
militarization of the police after the
colonies and degradation of the last two
years after Alonzo Guillen you must
atone not merely because the man you
support is a pig and you must now do
what is right but you must also do so in
self-defense because you are next
because the mall of racial hatred has
proved time and time again in nation
after nation to be insatiable and you
conservative black pastors and you
right-wing Hispanic leaders who still
support Trump and these racists today
you
find yourselves the victims of Trump and
these racists tomorrow the mothers kept
from the funerals will be yours the
lawns on which the torches will burn
will be yours with Dhaka the awful truth
is fully and finally upon us there are
two kinds of Trump supporters today
there are the racists who hate Mexicans
and all Hispanics and blacks and women
who think the playing field has somehow
been tilted against white men for half a
century and who have sold this hateful
bill of goods to those in this society
who have failed and are looking for
anybody to blame and then there are
those other Trump supporters who do not
have these vile hatreds in their
blackened Souls but who are still
willing to exploit and embrace those who
do and they are worse than the racists
because to them this is an opportunity
for power and on the existential subject
of right and wrong
they don't care while the time has come
where you have to care the sides are
being chosen now on the one there are
the principles and the values that have
led this nation from the peripheries of
influence to the primary place upon the
world stage and kept her here for a
century immigration assimilation the sum
of the parts the melting pot in theory
if not in fact and the striving awkward
insufficient often failing often tragic
but still the striving towards equality
and the strength and genius it creates
in this greatest of all nations and the
courage and the sacrifice of the true
embodiment of this nation a man like
Alonzo Guillen and on the other side
there is hatred and Prejudice and racism
and white grievance and scapegoating and
blame and revenge and stupidity and
shame and inhumanity and sheer
unapologetic cruelty and most of all
there is this scum Trump resist remove
peace